das Lager von Moria brennt lichterloh
vor drei Jahren auf der griechischen
Insel Lesbos
zuvor lebten hier bis zu 27.000 Menschen
und der erbärmlichen Bedingungen im
Lager sich selbst überlassen von der
Insel Lesbos durften sie nicht weg das
Lager sollte Menschen davor abschrecken
nach Europa zu flüchten
als die griechische Regierung Ende 2020
neue Lager bauen will geht die
Bevölkerung auf die Straße es kommt zur
Ausschreitungen die Demonstranten
greifen geflüchtete und
Sicherheitskräfte an
die Katastrophe von Lesbos ein
Wendepunkt die Europäische Kommission
erarbeitet in der Folge einen Vorschlag
zur Reform des gemeinsamen europäischen
Asylsystems kurz Geras eine Mehrheit
gibt es dafür lange nicht erst im Juni
dieses Jahres einigt sich schließlich
der Rat der Europäischen Innenminister
nun soll eine Reform unbedingt noch vor
der Europawahl 2024 kommen die sieht vor
geschlossene Lager beschleunigte
Asylverfahren und harter Grenzschutz an
Europas Außengrenzen
Sommer 2023 Lesbos viele Reformideen
sind hier bereits umgesetzt wir sind vor
Ort und wollen wissen kann geordnete
Migration an den Außengrenzen
funktionieren
die junge Afghanen verhäme miserer ist
seit Januar hier sie floh gemeinsam mit
ihrer Familie vor den Taliban und träumt
von einem Leben als selbstbestimmte Frau
sie erzählt uns seit mehreren Monaten
habe ihre ganze Familie einen positiven
Asylbescheid trotzdem geht es für Sie
und Ihre Familie nicht weiter
jedes Mal wenn wir dahin gehen und sagen
dass wir einen positiven Bescheid haben
und unsere Fingerabdrücke für den Pass
machen wollen sagen sie wir haben jetzt
keine Kapazität ihr müsst später noch
mal kommen
Israel geht es vielen geflüchteten
bestätigt uns Marion vom legal Center
Lesbos sie vertritt geflüchtete in ihren
Asylverfahren die beschleunigten
grenzverfahren missachten aus ihrer
Sicht rechtsstaatliche Prinzipien immer
weniger Menschen haben die Möglichkeit
sich juristische Hilfe zu suchen warum
wegen der beschleunigten Verfahren sie
werden durch die Interviews gepeitscht
zuvor sind sie in Quarantäne und haben
gar keinen Zugang zu irgendj
hinzu kommt die Türkei nimmt seit März
2020 keine geflüchteten mehr zurück die
griechischen Behörden lehnen trotzdem
Asylbewerber im Schnellverfahren ab ihr
Argument nach wie vor die Türkei sei ein
sicherer Drittstaat grease rejecting
Griechenland lehnt all diese
geflüchteten auf der Grundlage dass die
Türkei sicher sei ab aber sie schicken
sie auch nicht in die Türkei zurück sie
schicken sie nirgendwohin sie stecken
hier fest in einem juristischen
Schwebezustand
aufgehen muss die Politik vor Ort
dahinter stehen er ist dafür mit
verantwortlich Kostas muzuris seit 2019
Gouverneur der nordägischen Inseln
funktioniert aber wir sind nicht dafür
und wie schon gesagt habe warum hier auf
der Insel
Republik oder im Westeuropa
die EU will mit ihrer Reform die
Außengrenzen dicht machen und Migration
begrenzen gleichzeitig sollen die
Menschenrechte Gewalt bleiben
seit Jahren gibt es pushbacks und Gewalt
in der Ägäis nicht nur auf hoher See im
April dieses Jahres gelingt es erstmals
dieses Vorgehen komplett zu filmen
Schutzsuchende Menschen entführt von
maskierten Männern unter den Opfern sind
Frauen Kinder und ein Baby Verladen auf
ein Schiff der griechischen Küstenwache
von dort bringt man sie in Richtung
türkischer Gewässer ausgesetzt in einer
Rettungsinsel ihrem Schicksal
ausgeliefert
Gouverneur muzuus rechtfertigt die harte
Grenzpolitik und verteidigt die
pushbacks
das ist ein delikates Thema das Pushback
denn wenn man jemanden auch vorher sie
mitten in der Nacht zurückdrängt kommt
es vielleicht zu Unfällen
vielleicht sind manche Boote vielleicht
kommen manche leben aber manchmal ist es
notwendig aber ich bin nicht dafür
problemlos
migrationsvorschau Gerald Knaus gilt als
Vordenker vom migrationsabkommen mit der
Türkei die systematischen pushbacks der
griechischen Küstenwache hält er für
fatal
ich weiß vor kurzem wieder in Ankara die
türkische Sicht ist nachvollziehbar die
Türken sagen wir sehen jeden Tag die
pushbacks wir filmen sie bestellen Sie
auf die Webseite der türkischen
Küstenwache solange diese
illegalen pushbacks an unserer Grenze in
unserer Territorium hinein erfolgen
nehmen wir niemand zurück doch ohne
Abkommen mit Drittstaaten wie der Türkei
kann die Reform nicht gelingen um
Menschen davon abzuhalten über das
Mittelmeer zu kommen verhandelt die EU
derzeit vor allem mit den
Maghreb-Staaten auch
bundesinnenministerin nennt sie Feser
reist nach Tunesien das geht darum dass
furchtbare sterben im Mittelmeer zu
beenden große Worte aber noch während
die EU 900 Millionen Euro in Aussicht
stellt damit Tunesien die Migration
begrenzt lässt Präsident seit Schutz
Suchende ohne Wasser in der Wüste
aussetzen einige von ihnen verdursten
staatlicher Druck auf die geflüchteten
führt dazu dass in diesem Jahr Menschen
vor allem von Tunesien aus über das
Mittelmeer fliehen mehr als doppelt so
viele im Vergleich zum Feuer
auch auf Lesbos steigt seit April die
Zahl der Ankünfte wieder deutlich an zu
dieser Zeit sind über 3.200 Menschen im
Lager neue Kapazitäten haben die
griechischen Behörden trotzdem nicht
geschaffen geht es nach den Reformplänen
der EU sollen Neuankömmlinge in Zukunft
innerhalb von fünf Tagen registriert
werden
unrealistisch erklärt uns Nihal aus Mann
von Ärzte ohne Grenzen
es gibt aktuell fast 800 Menschen im
Camp die nicht registriert sind das
heißt dass sie keinen Zugang zu
irgendetwas haben die Lebensbedingungen
verschlechtern sich Menschen sind in
großen Katastrophen Zelten ohne Strom
ohne Matratzen
sie werden Wochen auf Ihre Registrierung
warten müssen
auch die Essensversorgung ist schlecht
stundenlang stehen sie hier für die
tägliche essensvergabe in der glühenden
Hitze an
verhindern und ihre Eltern bekommen im
Camp kein Essen mehr
alle Leute die nicht mehr immer
Asylverfahren sind also Asyl bekommen
haben oder abgelehnt wurden bekommen
kein Essen mehr nur noch die Kinder für
die anderen gibt es einmal pro Tag essen
am Mittag sie sagen das wären drei
Mahlzeiten aber das reicht nicht mal für
eine oft reicht es auch nicht für alle
die Bilder aus dem Camp wurden uns
zugespielt und selbst ist der Zugang zum
Lager untersagt Erik Marquardt
Europaabgeordneter der Grünen kann sich
ein Bild machen er glaubt nicht an den
Erfolg der EU-Reform
die Realität seit Jahren auf den
ägäischen Inseln und das ist eine ja man
versucht er hier auch schon mehrfach
gescheitert ist das klappt so lange
wenig Leute ankommen aber wenn mal mehr
ankommt dann ist das System überlastet
dann dauern die Asylverfahren länger
dann dauert die Registrierung ewig und
dann fühlen sich diese Lager überfüllen
sich auch und dann leiden die Leute
einfach
verhindern will nach Deutschland sobald
Sie Ihre Dokumente und das nötige Geld
hat in Griechenland hat sie Angst auf
der Straße zu landen